so imagine that a drunk driver hits you
and you'reyou're it crushes crushes your
leg and you're completely traumatized by
the events and they take you to the
hospital and just before your operation
they give you a pill to erase your
memory of this traumatic event or
imagine that you're a fellow soldier and
your soldier and your fellow soldier
gets blown up next to you and you're
very traumatized and again they give you
a pill to reduce the trauma of this
particular event or imagine that your
heroin addict and you are they give you
a drug so that so that you can forget
about your addiction in order to help
you with your addiction cells sounds
like something from a movie well
actually we're getting to be getting
pretty close to be able to do some of
these things so this is what we know now
and what we can do now basically
memories a system for storing and
recalling experiences our best account
of memory right now is as follows
basically we experience certain events
and a set of a network of neurons get
activated the the more significant the
event the more the stronger the
connections between the neurons when we
recall that particular event these
neurons get that network that particular
network gets reacted they get
reactivated again and so this is what we
can do to affect to modify our memories
one is we can affect it at the store the
storage level when it's about the gift
store when it's about to get transferred
from short-term memory to long-term
memory and the way to do that is to
affect the emotional strength of the
store the storing process so for example
propranolol the drug that's how it works
it works by weakening that that storage
a process that weak weakening the
emotional strength so that the the
memory doesn't get stored into the
long-term memory the other process is
through is by affecting the recall
of the memory basically each time when
each time you recall a memory the memory
has to reconsolidate itself again and
they meats proteins to do that and
there's it's been found that if there's
excess protein that can disrupt the
reconsolidation process thereby
weakening the memory the biggest
limitation to memory modification right
now is that basically as we have seen
that memories a network of neurons so
that means that basically it's
interconnected and it overlaps with one
another so that there's a danger that if
you delete one its you can delete other
memories so that's one of the biggest
limitations right now so suppose you can
perfect this technology what are some of
the ethical issues
well basically memory is a piece of
evidence so if you change your memory
you can change what you believe to be
true about the world and about yourself
so for example a soldier who takes
propranolol this may keep you may think
that he's not he really doesn't want to
be in the war when in fact he lasts
after the killing or you may believe
something about yourself you may think
that you're really brave or cowardly or
you may think that you're really
altruistic or selfish but if you take
some memory modification drugs you may
change what you believe to be true about
yourself but these problems are not so
worrying because one thing to remember
is that a bit of falsehood might not be
so problematic so if you wanted to
believe that you had a nice holiday so
that you can feel more relaxed that may
be ok as long as you don't harm anybody
another thing to remember is that if the
event is so important it's not really
just up to you because even if you can
erase the memory in yourself other
people will remember it so even if it
affects a bit of falsehood in you it
might not affect other people as well
okay so all
we the point of using these drugs is to
increase our personal well-being now
there's some obvious constraints to
pursuing personal well-being one obvious
constraint is of it is to sort of harm
to others if you want to take these
drugs so that you you can feel less
guilty when you commit a crime obviously
this would constitute a harm to others
and there another constraint is harm to
self an obvious example of that is if
you just wipe all of your memories that
would be in most many cases that would
be obvious harm to self but there are
also subtler forms of harm to self self
harm such as living in falsehood
affecting your the way you react to
certain situations morally and also your
duties to remember certain things but
ultimately the it seems that as long as
as long as you don't harm other people
you should be allowed to use these
memory modification drugs to in order to
improve your personal well-being
it's it's well you saw how they zapped
it right so basically the whole network
I think you're zapping the whole network
and that's going to be pretty difficult
without zapping other memories but the
way to do it I think it's basically if
you can get the right cues because
basically you cue the memory so if you
can cue it right then only those
networks come up and then use that that
then I think you can do it and actually
there's some evidence I'm doing that if
you look at fmi machines it's kind of it
seems like through correlations they can
begin to figure out which part is you
know what people are thinking or what
they're you know like when they're
imagining playing tennis as that tries I
trust certain parts of the brain lights
up and it seems like if you can get
enough consistency enough of a
correlation that this is that particular
memory then maybe you can begin to do
that but you'd have to do that many
times and get you know sort of a lot of
correlation and stuff like that I think
that would be the way to go